♫
>> Tucker: YOU’VE HEARD A
INSTITUTIONS ON THIS
PROGRAM.
WE NOW KNOW THE FBI IS
RIDDLED WITH INCOMPETENT
PARTISAN HACKS.
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
SEEMS TO EXIST MOSTLY TO SPY
ON YOU, AND LEAK INFORMATION
ABOUT POLITICIANS IT
DISLIKES.
YOUR STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE FULL OF
BUREAUCRATS WHO ARE PAID
MORE TO DELIVER LESS EVERY
YEAR.
AND THEN RETIRE WITH A FAT
PENSION IN THEIR 50’S.
ACADEMIA, MEANWHILE, IS
APPARENTLY DOMINATED BY LAZY
MEDIOCRITY AT THIS MORE
INTERESTED IN POLITICAL
ACTIVISM THAN TEACHING.
THERE IS A LOT OF ROT IN OUR
HALLS OF POWER BUT OUR
FEDERAL COURTS MAY BE THE
MOST DECAYED INSTITUTION OF
ALL.
THOUGH THEY RECEIVE VERY
LITTLE ATTENTION.
UNDER THE LAST TWO
ADMINISTRATIONS, THE COURTS
INCREASINGLY HAVE COME TO
SEE THEMSELVES NOT AS
INTERPRETERS OF THE LAW,
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE
BUT AS THE COUNTRY’S MAIN
POLICYMAKERS.
CONSIDER FOR EXAMPLE WHAT’S
BEEN HAPPENING WITH DACA.
NOW AS A FACTUAL MATTER IT
IS INDISPUTABLE THAT ANY
PRESIDENT HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO END DACA.
THE PROGRAM WAS A CREATION
FROM WHOLE CLOTH THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
IT HAS NO LEGAL BASIS ACTUAL
NOT WORK PERMITS.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
SIMPLY CHOSE TO IGNORE THAT
LAW, SETTING THE RIGHT OF
PROSECUTORIAL DISCRETION.
NOW, THE ARGUMENT COULD BE
VALID, THEORETICALLY, THOUGH
WE ARE SKEPTICAL.
HERE WHAT HAPPENS WE KNOW.
IF OBAMA CAN CHOOSE TO
IGNORE THE LAW, IT IS
OBVIOUS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS THE RIGHT
TO ENFORCE THE LAW.
THE LAW PASSED BY CONGRESS.
AND, YET, LEFT WING JUDGES
DISAGREE.
SEVERAL HAVE RULED ALREADY
IT IS SOMEHOW ILLEGAL TO END
DACA.
THEIR JUSTIFICATION FOR THIS
IS LEGALLY LUDICROUS.
LAST MONTH SAN FRANCISCO
DISTRICT COURT JUDGE WILLIAM
BLOCKED THE END OF DACA
NATIONWIDE.
HE SAID GETTING RID OF IT
WAS, QUOTE, ARBITRARY AND
CAPRICIOUS.
PART OF HIS RULING HE
ASSERTED DACA SHOULD
CONTINUE BECAUSE IT WAS,
QUOTE, IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST.  IN OTHER WORDS,
THE JUDGE LIKES THE PROGRAM,
THEREFORE, ENDING IT IS
ILLEGAL.
LAST WEEK ANOTHER JUDGE,
JUDGE NICHOLAS GARIFUS IN
NEW YORK RULED DACA CAN’T BE
ELIMINATED BECAUSE THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT
PROVIDED A VALID REASON FOR
ELIMINATING IT AS IF
FOLLOWING THE LAW WERE NOT
ENOUGH.
THE FIRST BIZARRE RULING
FROM THAT JUDGE IN 2010
GARAFUS ORDERED THE NEW YORK
FIRE DEPARTMENT USE RACIAL
QUOTE AS IT FOR HIRING
RATHER THAN MERIT TO ACHIEVE
GOALS HE HAD IN MIND RESULTS
WERE IMMEDIATE.
INJURIES WENT UP.
DROPOUT SURGED FROM 10% TO
24%.
LATER REVERSAL IN APPEALS
COURT SAID HIS BIAS WAS SO
BIAS AND SEVERE THAT PARTS
OF THE CASE HAD TO BE
ASSIGNED TO A NEW JUDGE YET,
OF COURSE, HE IS STILL ON
THE BENCH.
HE AND A LOT OF JUDGES LIKE
HIM.
IN MICHIGAN, A JUDGE HAS
BLOCKED THE DEPORTATION OF
CONVICTED IRAQI CRIMINALS IN
THIS COUNTRY CITING THE
ALLEGED DANGER THEY WOULD
FACE IF THEY RETURNED TO
THEIR OWN COUNTRY.
IT NEW YORK A JUDGE RELEASED
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT CRIMINAL
PRIOR TO DEPORTATION
CLAIMING HE HAD A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO,
QUOTE, SAY GOODBYE.
IN FLORIDA A JUDGE BLOCKED
THE DEPORTATION OF NEARLY
100 SOMALIS BECAUSE OF THE
CONDITIONS ON THE AIRPLANE
THAT WOULD FLY THEM HOME.
FOR REAL THAT HAPPENED.
THIS IS COMMONPLACE NOW.
IN THE NAME OF PROGRESSIVE
RESISTANCE TO THE PRESIDENT
ANYTHING CAN BE DECLARED
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND IS.
FOR EXAMPLE, IT’S BEEN
SETTLED LAW PRETTY MUCH
FOREVER THAT A PRESIDENT HAS
THE POWER TO EXCLUDE
FOREIGNERS FROM THE COUNTRY
BASED ON SECURITY CONCERNS.
BUT IN THE PAST YEAR,
MULTIPLE JUDGES HAVE IGNORED
THIS AND STRUCK DOWN THE
ADMINISTRATION’S TRAVEL
BANS.
SOME HAVE TAKEN THE LEGALLY
MEANINGLESS POSITION THAT
THE BANS WERE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BECAUSE OF
THINGS TRUMP SAID ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
JUDGE JAMES WYNN OF THE
FOURTH CIRCUIT COMPARED THE
PRESIDENT’S TRAVEL BAN TO
FDR’S INTERNMENT OF THE
JAPANESE PERSONAL CITIZENS
OF JAPANESE DISSENT DURING
THE SECOND WORLD WAR.
THAT’S NOT LEGAL ANALYSIS.
IT’S POLITICAL PUNDITRY.
GET THAT MAN A CNN CONTRACT.
FOR MORE THAN 200 YEARS THE
U.S. MILITARY DETERMINED WHO
COULD SERVE IN UNIFORM BASED
IN PART ON WHICH MEDICAL
CONDITIONS MIGHT NEGATIVELY
AFFECT A PERSON’S ABILITY TO
FIGHT WARS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THEM.
THAT MAKES SENSE, OF COURSE,
IT’S NO LONGER THE LAW
THANKS TO JUDGES.
IN HIS FINAL MONTHS IN
OFFICE, PRESIDENT OBAMA
DECLARED THE MILITARY MUST
ADMIT TRANSGENDERED SOLDIERS
REGARDLESS OF THE EFFECT ON
POLITICAL READINESS.
THAT WAS A POLITICAL
DECISION OBVIOUSLY.
THANKS TO ACTIVIST JUDGES IT
IS NOW A CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT SOMEHOW.
A JUDGE IN MARYLAND AND
COLLIN COLLIE OF THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA RULED
UNCONSTITUTIONAL TO BAR
TRANSGENDER VOLUNTEERS FROM
SERVICE.
THE RULING WENT ON TO ORDER
THE GOVERNMENT TO COVER
GENDER REASSIGNMENT SURGERY
AT TAXPAYER EXPENSE.
THESE JUDGES ARE NOT
INTERPRETING THE LAW.
MUCH LESS ENFORCING IT.
THEY ARE INVENTING THE LAW.
THEY REJECT THE CORE IDEA OF
DEMOCRACY, WHICH IS A
COUNTRY WHOSE POLICIES ARE
DETERMINED BY ITS CITIZENS.
ITS VOTERS.
THE JUDGES ARE IN CONTROL NO
MATTER WHAT YOU WANT OR WHO
YOU VOTED FOR.
INCREASINGLY THE ELECTED
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT ARE
IRRELEVANT.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE IN
THE ISSUES OF IMMIGRATION.
1980s LIMITED AMNESTY FOR
FARM WORKERS WAS SUPPOSED TO
END IN 1988.
THE COURTS RULED IT HAD TO
BE EXTEPSDED FURTHER.
THOUSANDS OF ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE WERE GIVEN AMNESTY
THEY WEREN’T SUPPOSED TO
RECEIVE.
LAWMAKERS WERE IGNORED.
1990S, CALIFORNIA VOTERS
OVERWHELMINGLY PASSED
PROPOSITION 187 BUT DENIED
STATE SOCIAL SERVICES TO
PEOPLE HERE ILLEGALLY.
COURTS GUTTED THAT LAW
WITHOUT EVEN ALLOWING IT TO
TAKE EFFECT AND NOW
CALIFORNIA’S ENTIRE MIDDLE
CLASS FLEEING THE STATE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION UTOPIA
SUITED FOR THE POOR AND VERY
RICH.
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT THE
VOTERS DIDN’T WANT BUT THE
JUDGES DIDN’T CARE.
HOW LONG BEFORE SOME JUDGE
ON THE NINTH CIRCUIT HAVE
THE ILLEGAL ALIENS CAN VOTE
IN OUR ELECTIONS BECAUSE
JUST BECAUSE.
SOME LAUGH BUT IT’S COMING.
JUDGES ARE ESSENTIAL.
THEIR JOB IS TO RESTRAIN
POLITICIANS HAVE FROM
TRAMPLING OUR CORE GOVERNING
PRINCIPLES.
BY CORE GOVERNING PRINCIPLES
WE MEAN ONES WRITTEN IN THE
CONSTITUTION NOT IN THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" EDITORIAL PAGE
OR AT THE BASE OF THE STATUE
OF LIBERTY.
OUR SYSTEM HAS WORKED WELL
FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS BUT
IT’S BREAKING APART.
IT’S BREAKING APART BECAUSE
OF JUDICIAL INTEGRITY.
THERE ISN’T ENOUGH OF THAT
FULL FIND YOURSELF ARGUING
THE CONSTITUTION DOES NOT
CONTAIN THE RIGHT TO KEEP
AND BEAR ARMS BUT DOES
CONTAIN A RIGHT TO ABORTION,
YOU ARE LYING.
THAT’S NOT A DIFFERENCE OF
INTERPRETATION, IT’S
DISHONESTY.
ONE IS IN THE TEXT.
ONE IS NOT.
RIGHT NOW THIS IS HAPPENING
ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY ON THE
LEFT.
IT’S NOT HARD TO IMAGINE
CONSERVATIVES DOING IT TOO.
WHY WOULDN’T THEY AFTER A
WHILE?
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN REPUBLICAN
APPOINTED JUDGES START
STRIKING DOWN LAWS A
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESS PASSED
ON TAXES HECK, ABORTION YOU
NAME IT SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
DON’T LIKE THEM.
THE JEWISH AREA WILL LOSE
WHATEVER HONOR IT ONCE HAD.
IT WILL BECOME A POLITICAL
WEAPON THAT HAS HAPPENED IN
A LOT OF COUNTRIES IT’S A
DISASTER A LOT OF TIMES.
JUDGES WHO MISUSE THEIR
POWER OUGHT TO BE CALLED TO
ACCOUNT.
THEY ARE NOT GODS.
THEY ARE GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS WHO WORK FOR US.
WHEN THEY ARE CORRUPT OR
DISHONEST, THEY OUGHT TO
FACE THE SAME CRITICISM AS
POLITICIANS OR BUREAUCRATS.
ABRAHAM LINCOLN ACCUSED.
THIS HIGH JUSTICE PROUDING
TO INCREASE SLAVERY.
HE WAS RIGHT.
THE ADMINISTRATION POINTS
OUT JUDICIAL MALFEASANCE AND
THERE IS A LOFT IT, THE
RULING CLASS RESPONDS WITH
HOWLS, THAT’S ATTACK ON
DEMOCRACY, THEY SAY.
>> I FIND THESE ATTACKS ON
THE JUDICIARY AN ABSOLUTELY
ABHORRENT AND UNACCEPTABLE.
>> I WILL BE HONEST, I DON’T
UNDERSTAND LANGUAGE LIKE
THAT WE DON’T HAVE SO-CALLED
JUDGES, WE DON’T HAVE
SO-CALLED SENATORS, WE DON’T
HAVE SO-CALLED PRESIDENTS.
>> SO-CALLED JUDGE, IS IT
APPROPRIATE FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO BE QUESTIONING
THE LEGITIMACY OF A FEDERAL
JUDGE IN THAT WAY?
DOESN’T THAT UNDERMINE THE
SEPARATION OF POWERS AND THE
CONSTITUTION WRITTEN RIGHT
NEXT DOOR?
>> Tucker: THEY ARE LIE
TALKING AS THEY ALWAYS DO.
IT’S NOT ANTI-DEMOCRATIC TO
DEMAND THE PUBLIC’S VIEWS
SHOULD FUNDAMENTALLY SHAPE
PUBLIC POLICY.
THAT’S THE ESSENCE OF
DEMOCRACY ITSELF.
JONATHAN TEMPERATURE SOLID
PARTICULARLY DISTINGUISHED
PROFESSOR AT GEORGE
WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY LAW
SCHOOL.
AND HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
PROFESSOR, THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
>> THANKS.
>> Tucker: THAT’S KIND OF
THE ESSENCE OF THE WHOLE
DEBATE IS TO WHAT EXTENT
SHOULD PUBLIC POLICY BE
GUIDED BY THE PUBLIC’S VIEWS
IN A DEMOCRACY AND OBVIOUSLY
THERE STRURECKETSD,
CONGRESS, JUDICIARY, HE CAN
EXECUTIVE.
BASICALLY IF YOU GET TOO FAR
FROM WHAT THE PUBLIC WANTS
IT’S NOT DEMOCRACY.
>> WE HAVE LIMITED
DEMOCRACY.
YOU ELECT PEOPLE TO MAKE
DECISIONS FOR YOU.
YOU HOPEFULLY WON’T HAVE TOO
MUCH OF A DISCONNECT AT THE
END OF THE DAY BETWEEN THE
POLICIES BEING PURSUED
ULTIMATELY THOSE LAWS HAVE
TO BE WRITTEN BY PEOPLE WHO
ARE POLITICAL
REPRESENTATIVES.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
>> AND THAT MEANS THAT THE
COURTS MUST WE TAKEN A
FAIRLY NARROW ROLE IN THIS
SYSTEM OTHERWISE THE SYSTEM
DOESN’T WORK.
MADISON CREATED A SYSTEM BY
WHICH FACTIONAL INTERESTS
WAS SORT OF ROLL AROUND
BETWEEN THE LEGISLATIVE AND
EXECUTIVE BRANCH IN
CONGRESS.
OUT OF THAT WOULD COME THE
MAJOR TARREN COMPROMISE.
WORK OUT OUR DIFFERENCES.
THAT SYSTEM ONLY WORKS IF
THERE IS NO ALTERNATIVE TO
THAT SYSTEM.
IF YOU START TO MAKE
DECISIONS, FOR EXAMPLE, IN
THE COURTS THAT ARE REALLY
POLITICAL DECISIONS, IT
TAKES THE SYSTEM OFF LINE.
AND THAT’S WHAT HAS GIVEN US
THE STABILITY.
YOU HAVE COUNTRIES LIKE
FRANCE THAT WENT THROUGH
CONSTITUTIONS WITH ALMOST A
SEASONAL REGULATOR.
AND THEY WERE VERY UNSTABLE.
OURS HAS BEEN STABLE.
YOU CAN SAY A LOT OF THINGS
ABOUT PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE,
BUT WE’RE STILL HERE.
WE HAVE GONE THROUGH
INCREDIBLE PRESSURES AND
PERIODS.
AND WE’RE STILL HERE.
AND IT’S LARGELY DUE TO THE
FACT THAT WE ALL HAVE SORT
OF SKIN IN THE GAME.
WE ALL KNOW THAT IF WE
RESPECT THE POLITICAL SYSTEM
THAT IS WORTH WORKING FOR
CHANGE.
>> Tucker: I AGREE WITH THAT
COMPLETELY.
I HAVE ALWAYS BELIEVED IN
OUR SYSTEM AND I WANT TO
BELIEVE IN IT.
BUT IF YOU HAVE JUDGES WHO
CLEARLY AREN’T EVEN MAKING A
GOOD FAITH EFFORT TO PRETEND
THAT THEIR DECISIONS
CORRESPOND TO THE TEXT IN
THE CONTUSION, DON’T THE
REST OFS HAVE YOU A RIGHT TO
SAY SOMETHING ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT THERE
IS NO PROBLEM OF CRITICIZING
THE COURTS.
EVERY PRESIDENT IN MODERN
TIMES HAS TAKEN THE COURTS
TO TASK.
AND THEY HAVE ALL PLEDGED TO
CHANGE THE COURTS ON THE
LEFT OR THE RIGHT.
THAT’S A NATURAL PART OF THE
PROCESS.
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN YOU
CROSS THE LINE.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
>> THE PRESIDENT’S CRITICISM
OF THE ETHNICITY OF THAT ONE
JUDGE CROSSED THE LINE.
>> Tucker: I HATED THAT I
AGREE WITH YOU, I HATED
THAT.
THAT DOESN’T MEAN THAT IF A
JUDGE DOESN’T SEE THE RIGHT
TO BEAR ARMS, WHICH IS
WRITTEN EXPLICITLY IN THE
BILL OF RIGHTS BUT SOMEHOW
IMAGINES THE RIGHT TO
ABORTION WHICH IS NOWHERE TO
BE FOUND.
WE TAKE THAT FOR GRANTED BUT
IT’S VERY COMMON.
DOESN’T THAT RAISE THE
QUESTION LIKE, WHAT?
WHERE DOES THAT COME FROM?
>> I THINK THE PEOPLE OF
GOOD FAITH CAN DISAGREE ON
THESE ISSUES.
I THINK ISSUES OF THE SECOND
AMENDMENT, ABORTION, THESE
ARE ALL ISSUES-OUT THE
SECOND AMENDMENT IS
EXPRESSED IN TERMS OF
ABORTION THE COURT REFERS TO
AS A RIGHT.
WE CAN DISAGREE ABOUT THOSE
THINGS AND DO IT CIVILLY.
THERE IS NO PROBLEM WITH
CITIZENS OR PRESIDENT SAYING
THAT’S JUST NOT WHAT THE LAW
SAYS.
THAT’S NOT WHAT WE CREATED
AS A FREE.
>> Tucker: WE’RE IN CHARGE.
GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS DOES